-I'm so happy
you're still with us.
-Yes. [ Laughs ]
-I mean, I can't believe
that you did this
this morning, right?
-I can't believe
I did it either.
-Yeah.
-I want to get into all of this.
I want to also
get into the tour.
And look at how fun
the album is.
-Yeah. Brand-new album.
Just came out a month ago.
It's called
"It's the End of the World
but It's a Beautiful Day."
And it's our --
It's kind of true.
Especially in these crazy times.
-Yeah.
-And we just put a brand-new
single, called "Seasons."
We're putting it out now,
on Monday.
And we have
a huge announcement today.
And this is the reason I climbed
the Empire State Building,
because Thirty Seconds to Mars,
after six years,
we're going back on the road.
We announced a world tour.
And -- Yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Chord plays ]
-It's amazing.
-What -- You could have just
come on our show and said that.
-Yeah.
-You realize. Right?
I mean, you didn't have to...
-Oh, there it is.
Oh, wow.
-Yeah, you could just -- Here.
-Yeah
-You could just hold this.
I mean, these are all
practical buildings.
-The only problem is,
this is the Chrysler Building.
-Oh, yeah. Sorry about that.
Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
[ Muttering ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Yeah, yeah.
Yeah, it's that one.
But the tower's
been knocked off.
-It's this one, right?
-Uh...
No, it's that one there.
-It's this.
-Yeah, yeah.
-Yeah.
-No, no, no.
-That's 30 Rock.
-No, no, it's -- it's missing.
[ Laughter ]
-We don't have
the Empire State Building?
-It's on the wall.
-Oh, there it is.
Oh, it's in the screen.
[ Laughter ]
You can't...
[ Laughs ]
It's real, it's real. Sorry.
Wow!
It's the biggest building
on our backdrop.
Sorry. But anyways...
[ Laughs ]
-Both of us are like...
But...
[ Laughter ]
But, dude, can I just say --
I mean, I can't believe
I'm never --
never, ever
gonna meet King Kong.
And so I get to meet
someone else
who climbed
the Empire State Building.
This is fascinating.
What goes through your mind?
How do you even start it up
and go like,
"Hey, I have a weird idea"?
Like, who do you call?
-You know,
it's a great question.
It's a really good question,
but ever since I was a kid,
I was fascinated with
the Empire State Building.
It, to me, was a symbol
of New York City,
and New York City
was a symbol of a place
that you go to make
your dreams come true.
I love this city, and
I always wanted to live here.
I always wanted to be an artist.
And you know, for me --
And I don't know
if it was King Kong
or if it was, like,
the Guinness World Record,
but there was something
about that building.
I even had, like, a little toy
when I was a kid --
a little metal replica.
That would have been perfect
here.
[ Laughter ]
-We'll make a note --
next time you come here,
we'll get
an Empire State Building.
Yeah.
-So, yeah, it was just --
It was just a dream of mine.
I loved the climb,
and it just seemed like
one of those impossible things.
And it was very impossible
when we started.
We got 10,000 nos
before we got a single maybe.
And even then, we just really
got the final word
a couple of days ago.
-Which part of the building
did you climb, exactly?
Like, the red part?
-Yeah, a little below that.
But I'll tell you,
this is called the fin,
the red part.
And that's
the most exciting part
because you really feel like
you're floating above the city.
It's incredible.
And I wish I had a little video,
but what I climbed
are basically little --
I put my feet on bolts.
They're tiny, little bolt heads.
And then I put my my hands on
either side of the windowsills,
which are quite sharp.
You can see
my hands are pretty beat up
from the climb.
-Oh, my gosh.
It's not meant for climbing.
-Yeah.
-No, it's not.
They didn't build that
for for climbing.
-Appreciate you watching me
while I climbed today.
-No problem. Yeah.
I couldn't believe that.
You have great eyesight.
[ Laughter ]
We actually have a video
of you doing the climb.
Let's take a look at you
in action here.
We don't have any audio.
We can talk over it.
But this is this morning.
That's Jared.
That is you, buddy.
-Yeah, that's me.
-I mean, wow!
-Yeah, I saw somebody...
[ Cheers and applause ]
I saw somebody online.
A friend of mine sent me a note
saying a guy was convinced
it's A.I., that it wasn't real.
But it's actually
very, very real.
-You have the scabs to prove it.
-The scabs to prove it, yeah.
-Were you nervous at all?
-You know, I wasn't.
I really was so excited
to do it.
It was very cold.
We got up at 3:15
in the morning,
which was fun.
And it was about 41 degrees.
And I mean, it just added to it.
The wind was really intense
up there, too.
-Why did you choose
that time of day?
-Well, we wanted
to get the sunrise,
and it was part
of the arrangement
that we made
to do it at that time,
because there are no people
on the observation deck.
-People normally climb
the Empire State Building
later, lunch time.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
-12:30 1:00, everyone's climbing
the Empire State Building.
-I think what they meant was,
they didn't want me
to fall on someone
and hurt them.
[ Laughter ]
Which is very nice.
-I can't believe
that you did this, buddy.
I'm seriously in awe of this
and in awe of you.
-Well, we haven't toured
in six years,
and I wanted to do
something special.
And our concerts are
about spontaneity.
They're aspirational
in some ways,
and really about
just living dreams.
And this, to me, it's been
a longtime dream of mine.
-This is a world tour
you're doing?
-Yeah, it's a world tour.
And you know,
it's a long time coming.
You know, my brother and I
are so excited
to get back out there.
Thirty Seconds to Mars
has been gone for a long time,
and we're ready.
-Your brother --
But you also then sang a song
after you climbed.
-Yeah.
-First of all,
here's you just
sitting on the ledge going,
"Yeah, I did that."
-Yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-[ Chuckles ]
That's pretty --
That's pretty cool.
And then I actually have a video
of you and your brother singing
"Seasons," your new song,
at the top of
the Empire State Building
this morning.
Let's take a look
at that cool moment.
-♪ People, they come,
and people, they go ♪
♪ When the leaves change
and the colors they show ♪
♪ Can you hold on
through the seasons? ♪
♪ Through the seasons, oh ♪
-Yeah, I mean, come on,
that's...
[ Cheers and applause ]
You took what the Beatles
did on "Abbey Road,"
when they performed
on the rooftop,
and you topped them
by like six stories.
-It was just --
It was a beautiful thing.
And it's funny, sometimes
when you do concerts
or little shows like that,
it can feel
a little stiff or stale
because there was no audience.
But it felt really amazing
to be up there with my brother,
and it was
an incredible experience.
It was cool.
-Did you feel like
you were just looking
at a model of the city?
I mean, did it look
like New York City?
-You know, it does.
It's the New York
that we all know and love,
and it's a beautiful thing
to wake up
with that city like that,
to watch the sun rise,
to see that that whole city.
On one side --
You know, Empire has 360 views,
and on one side,
you see Central Park
and all the way north,
and the other side, you see
all the way down
to One World Trade.
And it's incredible.
I mean, I wish you could come
and do it with me sometime.
-No, I'm busy that day,
but I would love to do it.
I'm so happy for you.
-I hope that you come to a show.
We're going to play Barclays
in...
-I'll definitely be there
in Brooklyn.
I will be there, absolutely.
It's on the ground?
-Yeah.
-Absolutely.
I will be there.
I love this guy.
Jared Leto --
one in a million, buddy.
-You're the best.
Check out his new album
and his upcoming world tour.
More "Tonight Show"
after the break.
Stick around, everybody.